I'm Dana Perino I'm Jason Chaffetz I'm
Rachel Campos Duffy and this is the Fox
News Rundown
[Music]
April 14th 2020
s Foster and inflation isn't going away
it seems like what the administration
has chosen so far to do is not at least
in the short term paying off they are
promising it will more in the long term
but again the polling shows that people
blame this white house we're speaking of
Fox News Sunday host Shannon bream I'm
Jessica Rosenthal Republicans need six
seats to gain control of the house and
one of the races they're excited about
in these upcoming midterms is a redrawn
district that leans Blue by double
digits I don't and put my party first
that's the difference between my
opponent and I he is all about kids
party I'm all about the American people
and I'm David bossi I've got the final
word on the Fox News Rundown
[Music]
there's not much if any relief in the
labor Department's monthly report on
inflation it's Consumer Price Index but
we pay for everyday Goods housing and
services is up 8.2 percent annually with
prices four tenths of a percent higher
in September than August both more than
most economists expected we are acutely
aware of the pressures that this causes
on American families White House
economic adviser Jared Bernstein on Fox
News Channel Texas house Republican
Kevin Brady on Fox Business it's clear
we're going to see high inflation it's
persistent uh and right now there's no
end inside groceries are up 13 from a
year ago housing 6.6 percent the fastest
since 1991. generally we know
historically that voters tend to blame
the person who's in power the party
that's in power that makes sense to them
if they're struggling what was it decade
to go it's about the economy stupid and
that tends to be what really runs most
elections Shannon bream's the host of
Fox News Sunday it's going to get
tougher for the White House in that OPEC
has now got this 2 million Barrel a day
cut that's only going to drive gas
prices up which we know then there's the
ripple effect everything else for
transporting food and energy and all
those other things so it's not a great
report for the White House the core
number is not good it's up significantly
so I think that they know that voters
make people pay in elections when it
comes to the economy and so they'll be
doing everything they can to message
that they've made Investments the
inflation reduction act you got to wait
to see some of these things pay off but
they're on the job as part of your
research and your job and whatever um
have you tried to become a little bit
more of an economist
um I've tried my best but I it doesn't
seem like anything's working yeah I'm no
expert I do fall back on my you know I
have a business degree so I think back
to the econ classes I took in college
should have probably paid attention a
little bit more but that's what I love
about this job is that we are constantly
learning more and I definitely would say
that about the economy there are a
couple economists I love to call them up
and say okay this wonky report or number
what does this actually mean how does
this translate into real life so we have
great people like that that we can rely
on but it's true it seems like what the
administration has has chosen so far to
do is not at least in the short term
paying off they are promising it will
more in the long term but again the
polling shows that people blame this
white house they think there's a new
polling out this week that actually half
of Americans think not that this federal
government or the bite Administration
has been neutral they actually assign
them as making things worse and that's
tough yeah and again if you're driving
around and that gas station price thing
is almost like a free advertising for
whoever the opposition has to be happens
to be
um people don't care that inflation is
about the same in the European Union or
whatever's going on that's their problem
I'm worried about my problem uh and
millions of Americans are already voting
absentee in some states uh let's talk
about the new Fox News Power Rankings um
same as last month still has the
Republicans winning back the house best
gas 231 seats to 204 there are 30
something toss-ups in there and there's
a best case scenario for the Democrats
where they could hold but um it's you
know maybe 20 something like that well
it's interesting because you have people
out there who don't trust the polls in
either direction
um you know I've I've interviewed
Republicans who say they're worried that
people will become complacent earlier in
the year when they were more favored to
pick up more seats in the house and the
Senate
um I think that you know you got to
think about enthusiasm and getting your
voters out there there had been more of
an enthusiasm advantage to Republicans
that Gap has closed in some polls it
shows Democrats are actually gaining
ground there it's all about turnout like
you said some of this early stuff is
already starting some states where they
haven't even had the debates yet in some
of these races so
um there's so much that can happen
um you know three four weeks is a
lifetime in politics and there's always
the potential for a November surprise
plenty in October room in November uh
looking at the Senate our esteemed
political team has it uh it's a toss-up
really um with just four races deciding
to Balance power in Pennsylvania Georgia
Arizona Nevada Pennsylvania is getting a
lot of National Air Time with the
Democrat John fetterman they're trying
to Democrats trying to flip that seat to
Democrat
um it started this conversation but what
maybe is and what isn't a disability and
what how fetterman's stroke and his
problems processing language could
affect his job now you can make the case
and they have made the case that well if
you're a deaf Senator it's it's no
different and and fetterman says look
I'm getting better this isn't a
cognitive thing it's just language
processing yeah um it could go either
way he could get sympathy or he could
scare people off I suppose it's got It's
very tricky and with his opponent being
an MD an actual doctor that's tricky
because he actually knows the prognosis
of a patient better than us as lay
people would know but you have to be
very careful in the public opinion
sphere because people don't want to
think that anyone is being bullied or
marginalized or embarrassed because of a
physical issue and listen he could wind
up being a senator and go to the Senate
and and have a screen in front of him to
help him process speeches and things
that are going on there like you said
it's not cognitive he understands it may
be communicating back and forth it's
difficult for him so it's tricky because
he'll go around and say how dare a
doctor be making fun of me and Oz will
say I'm not making fun of him I'm trying
to say that this is an issue that I
understand from a medical Viewpoint that
race has tightened it has not been this
close
um I don't think ever in Oz's favor
tightening yes tightening in his favor
but fetterman has had a very strong lead
and when you look at the gubernatorial
race there too A distinct Advantage for
the Democrat so you got to look at how
the down ballots play off of each other
I would still say if I was a betting
person that fetterman pulls this out
we'll see
uh Wisconsin Democrat Mandela Barnes
trying to take Ron Johnson senate seat
the Republican we're told that President
Biden has a particular disdain
for Ron Johnson
um do you do we know why and how hard
are the Democrats is a machine fighting
for that seat
um I
sure what the rub is between the two of
them um
times that Senator Johnson has been very
been a defender of President Trump on
certain issues and maybe that's part of
it election related and those kinds of
things but that's a tough race for
Democrats in that the more that people
learn about the Challenger there the
more they feel like he is radical
potentially on things like crime which
we know along with the economy is the
other top issue that people really care
about more broadly we're gonna get new
polls out this weekend on Fox News
Sunday if I might put in a plug
um but I think that's one of those races
that has um that's where you've seen the
Republican in most polls benefit the
more people learn about the Democratic
Challenger that's the opposite for the
parties in some of these other states
we talked last time about the Georgia
race uh the the Herschel Walker abortion
allegations had just come out
um he's actually if I'm reading the
polls right he may have gone up a little
bit since those allegations came out or
at least flat against on the Democrat
Rafael Warnock I don't know if people
just don't care about abortion or the
fact that he may or may not be lying
about it
um or if or if this is just a thing that
happens as the race gets you know as we
get close to election day and people
rally around their guy they may because
what he does so well with people who are
considering voting for him is is often
what president Trump does very well to
say this is proof that the establishment
doesn't want me to go there and
represent you so I think that line of
argument probably has worked for people
who were maybe interested in Walker I
think he's going to lose some people who
say like okay I don't want to get
involved with this candidate that's not
my guy but there's been polling all over
the place for him I think that is a very
interesting one to watch to see which
poll is most accurate because there are
some that show him way down there's some
that show him a potentially holding or
moving up and that's the stew of looking
at all of these different polls and how
they they play you know there's a
political reporter there in Georgia who
was covering this race for them and she
says yes everybody in the Beltway is
talking about this stuff she said but
tonight with lead in the local newscast
is crime crime crime in Atlanta so she
says you know the wonky Beltway people
may be more worried about this stuff
than local voters are we'll see Fair
Arizona Senator Mark Kelley's been
pretty consistently up in the polls uh I
know pull pole but it's what we have to
talk about at this point against the
Republican uh Challenger Blake Masters
but the lead again maybe narrowing a
little bit um Republicans may be with a
little more hope with taking that
possibly then this gets into this
conversation where pollsters will say
there's the silent voter or is that the
conservative or the Trump voter
um AKA who does not want to give the
truth to a pollster or doesn't want to
participate in the poll in the first
place I mean some polls are very good at
factoring that in we'll have to see if
they do that this time around but that's
been an exceptionally tight race as has
the gubernatorial race there two so
Arizona is definitely one to watch one
we maybe haven't paid as much about
nationally is in Nevada which is
considered the other toss-up of the four
um the Democrat incumbent Catherine
Cortez Mastro is running against Adam
laxalt this is when the Republicans
really think they can grab and they need
to if they think they're going to win
control back of the Senate this is uh
you know it's in that handful of two or
three that's like you got to pull it out
um I was out in Vegas not long ago to
give a speech not doing anything fun
everything in Vegas stays there
um but you know when you travel to these
different states you're inundated with
their local ads and it was so much about
abortion on both sides the ads weren't
about the economy which is not what the
Democrats want to be talking about right
now but it was about abortion non-stop
even from the Republicans yeah I mean
and there was sort of this idea that
maybe they were explaining or clarifying
where laxalt is on that issue but I was
surprised that that seemed to be the
overarching theme and nearly every ad I
saw there uh one more booster is
approved for kids 5 and Up it struck me
when this news came out that there was a
time that this would have been Sirens
blaring flat you know every time a
vaccine was approved and now it just
seems like okay great another another
Tick Tock Yeah in our in our new coveted
life even though Long coveted and medium
covered we're hearing more and more
about
um is anybody at this point talking
about this stuff on the campaign Trail
talking about the shutdowns or how the
pandemic may or may not have been
handled or mishandled or have we just
moved past that I think that um it
doesn't show up in polling as an issue
thank God that people are is it top of
mind right now and I think that walking
around New York right now it's like the
most normal it's felt to me in two and a
half
years
um there wasn't a good uptake on shots
for youngsters and so I think that you
know the now that the booster is
available there's certain people who
they were first in line they're
definitely going to think this is the
best choice for their kid and be there
to get it
um I don't hear a lot on the campaign
Trail about this particular issue but
there are those who will invoke it to
say don't forget what the last two years
were like if you didn't like that if you
felt the Democrats didn't handle it well
and infringed on your your personal
freedom in a way that you did not like
for you or your children then vote for
me it's not a top liner but it does
sneak in there it's a thing in the main
gubernatorial race I know that you can
come but they're Democrat Janet Mills
that's that's something that she's been
getting hammered on um lockdowns Etc et
cetera against um Paula page who's the
Republican trying to get that right
trying to get that job back right it's
interesting when people leave the job
and then they come to fight try to get
it back but that one I think we just
moved to lean Democrat so we'll see yeah
the page like many people in Maine
decided to um head off to Florida for a
bit and then came back trying to get his
whole job back Shannon bream host of Fox
News Sunday thank you great to see you
foreign
[Music]
with your Fox News commentary coming up
it was a big upset at the time when
mexican-born Republican Myra Flores won
Texas District 34 along the border in a
special congressional election held this
summer Republican House minority leader
Kevin McCarthy said after she took on
the role you know the sign out front
says historic
because moments ago we watched a moment
of History
Myra Flores was officially sworn in he
noted the seat had been held by
democrats for decades in a district that
is according to ballot pedia 84 Hispanic
she's facing Democratic Congressman
Vicente Gonzalez in November but Flores
is the incumbent though the redrawn
lines created a district President Biden
would have won according to the Fox News
power rankings by 15 points Gonzalez is
currently Congressman in the 15th
District in Texas but he opted to run in
the 34th telling the Texas Tribune he
still would have won in the 15th but it
would have been a bigger challenge he's
been on offense posting a video to one
Texas County's Democratic Facebook page
and I want to ask everyone to join me in
asking my opponent Myra Flores for the
debate that we had agreed to on October
the 19th people of South Texas deserve
to hear both sides the Flores campaign
said you can't pull out of something you
never agreed to noting they didn't even
hear from the TV station about a debate
until last week and already had a
scheduling conflict furthermore they say
the Gonzalez campaign never tried to
negotiate another date Gonzalez though
is fighting to stay in congress
alongside two other South Texas
Democrats all of whom are facing
Republican Latino women he told MSNBC in
Late July we're clear to take this back
in November and kick the Republicans out
in South Texas voters in South Texas are
very smart very clever very informed uh
November is going to be a shock for
Republicans down here that remains to be
seen as the Fox News Power Rankings have
now moved this seat from lean Democrat
to toss-up well we're focusing on the
issues that matter to them Myra Flores
is the Republican congresswoman in Texas
District 34 and we spoke to her while
she was traveling on the campaign Trail
you know and my constituents want me to
focus on them and they're the ones that
elected me to be in this position
so I owe myself to them so I'm focused
on border security and I'm focused on
the economy these are the things that
they're talking to me every single day
they're concerning to them and it's my
top priority to bring economic
opportunities to Texas 34 and it's my
top priority to secure the borders
I know you're on the road now you said
you're meeting with farmers and ranchers
I know that that's you did that this
week as well earlier in the week we've
been hearing about the cost of diesel
for Farm Vehicles the cost of fertilizer
everything that goes into farming has
been hit as we see inflation I know the
the Biden Administration has said
they've doubled their investment in
domestic fertilizer production grants
and they've increased insurance to cover
double cropping
is that helpful do you support those
kind of efforts or are you seeing
something else that is needed that
farmers are telling you about
they're going through the
building and a humanitarian crisis the
open borders are really the reason why
they're hurting tremendously as well of
course inflation is also one of the
reasons why they're hurting us
tremendously but the bite Administration
hasn't been able to come here to South
Texas to come and see what their
policies are doing to us here in South
Texas what it's doing to our farmers and
the impact that it's having in their
lives and if you were to come here is
Kamala Harris would come here to South
Texas they would I would hope that they
would realize that what they're doing is
not just hurting us here in South Texas
it's hurting the entire country and it's
time to make a U-turn and put it back in
place the policies that we're working
and start enforcing the laws and allow
our border patrol agents to do that our
border patrol agents are focused on the
humanitarian crisis and they're not able
to stop the fentanyl that is coming in
into our country that it's killing our
children the future of this country I
don't know when border security became a
political issue because it shouldn't be
political this is something that both
Democrats and Republicans should be
working together let's focus on legal
immigration improving the legal process
so we could allow the good people that
want to come here to work hard for the
American Dreams but that they can do it
legally because illegal immigration is
funding criminal organization women and
children are going through abuse and
rape and close to a thousand immigrants
have already died going through this
dangerous Journey
no one deserves that
you're married to a border patrol agent
right I'm married to a border patrol
agent and I understand 100 where our
border patrol agents are going to let
the border patrol wise and you've
already worked on a bill with Democrats
I would note to open up um I guess
they're called fusion centers along the
border two of them to help law
enforcement coordinate and work together
tell me why that was one of your I guess
first focuses when it came to the Border
when you became a congressperson because
it's so important that all our law
enforcement even at the local level and
state level have that communication
because that's how we miss things and
I'm focused on things that we can both
agree on both sides and that's what we
need to focus on we're so focused on
what we disagree but can we work on what
we agree on can we give our border
patrol agents to resources that they
need to Manpower a tire more border
patrol agents let's give them the
technology that they need to secure the
Border but Washington is playing
politics with human lives playing
politics with our border patrol agents
it's not fair for our border patrol
agents it's not fair for our border
patrol agents families and it's not fair
for the Border towns that are hurting
right now tremendously we are at Max
Capacity the humanitarian crisis is not
a South Texas problem this is an
American problem it is time that New
York California and all these Sanctuary
cities step up and help us we can't do
it anymore we've been doing it for over
two years already all on our own and
we're in desperate times in South Texas
but it's time for the federal government
to step up there are biggest problems
I have to ask you about your race you're
on the you're on the campaign Trail as
we speak you're running against a
current Congressman Vincent Gonzalez and
after redistricting our own Fox News
Power Rankings say this seat would have
gone for President Biden by 15 points
that is a lot but the rankings also now
rate this seat as a toss-up why do you
think that is what do you hear from
constituents about that
well they're not supporting the Bible
they don't support President Biden they
don't support his policies and he
doesn't care about checking District 34.
why would the people of District 34
continue supporting President Biden
after completely abandoning us in South
Texas and ignoring our needs
the people of Texas 34 want a real
representation in Washington I've been
focused 100 in my constituents I'm
focused on the issues that matter to
them for me it's all about my district
I don't put my party first that's the
difference between my opponent and I he
is all about his party
I'm all about the American people
I put my constituents first in their
needs and that's the reason why so many
people are walking away but I'll be
friends with you the Democrat Party has
abandoned the Hispanic Community to
cater to the far left
South Texas regardless of politics has
always been a community of God
family and hard work
that is who we are it's in our DNA and
our roots are still very strong with our
heritage in Mexico I was born in Mexico
raised with those values values that
were instilled in me
and that live within me and that I
instill those values into my children
and I want our values the values of
South Texas to live forever in our
community and I want our values to be
instilled into our children that's what
makes us unique that's the American
dream
finally you've been talked about in
connection with Cassie Garcia who's
running in the 28th District against
Henry Cuellar and Monica De La Cruz
running in the 15th for an open seat
against Democrat Michelle Vallejo
Republicans are very excited about this
group this grouping here and I think I
think you just kind of addressed it but
what do you think may be driving some of
that shift among some of these South
Texas Latino voters to be more open to
Republican messaging
well they're seeing someone like them
they're seeing someone that represents
their values and they're seeing someone
that is putting their children their
Community First
and we are sick and tired of being
treated like second class and we have
been treated like second class for a
long time you know and we're American
our voice matters too
and no one cared about South Texas
under their leadership and now that I am
a member of Congress they're talking
about South Texas they're talking about
our needs and we finally have a seat in
the table
and we are the majority in Texas and we
will be the future that is why it's so
important that we continue investing in
the Hispanic Community you know both
parties do not have a future without the
Hispanic Community the Republican party
doesn't have a future without the
Hispanic community so it is so important
that we invest in the Hispanic community
and that we fight for their best
interests as well because at the end of
the day we are also Americans
congresswoman I have to ask one more
before I let you go I I was I was
reading that you have said you are
pro-life
um and I was also reading that that
means no exceptions for you do you make
exceptions for the life of a mother or
rape or are there any exceptions in your
mind
there are exceptions I don't know where
um there's been a lot of misinformation
I'm pro-life
um I do believe that there is exceptions
especially when
um the mother's lives at risk we but the
Democrat Party has gone so radical that
they support abortion up to nine months
with no restrictions and that's what my
opponent actually voted for the last
bill he voted for abortion of nine
months with no restrictions and as a
mother
um a [ __ ] that knows what it's like to
carry a child up to nine months that is
honestly
um just so disturbing to know that
there's people that support abortion up
to nine months with no uh with no
restrictions
um and I don't know how we I don't know
how we got here you know and honestly
the generation in a district that leans
bluish right even according to our own
data here has that gotten in the way at
all do you feel like that issue is we're
a Hispanic Community where people we're
a Hispanic Community there's a huge
difference we're South Texas there's a
big difference between South Texas and
and Austin and there's a big difference
between South Texas and California and
New York we value life here and Texas
District 34 does not support abortion up
to nine months with no restriction
well congresswoman Amira Flores thank
you so much for joining us
thank you thank you so much God bless
you
[Music]
Jason and the house the Jason Chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as I take on American
Life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you download podcasts Raiden
review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen it's
time for your Fox News commentary David
what's on your mind every two years
there seems to be a competitive race for
the United States Senate that emerges
out of nowhere that wasn't on anyone's
radar screen when the election cycle
first began
this year's sleepy campaign in
Washington state between far left
Democrats Senator Patty Murray a
five-year career Washington D.C
politician and first-time candidate
Republican Tiffany Smiley is it recent
polling shows the decades-long liberal
incumbent Murray polling below 50
percent despite her High name
recognition against Smiley who until
recently was seen as a little-known
citizen politician shockingly the ballot
test in two of these polls had Senator
Murray's lead shrinking to just two and
three points respectively
these results have Washington D.C
buzzing with Intrigue about what might
be happening on the ground in the
reliably Democrat stronghold of
Washington in the Pacific Northwest
to make matters worse for Senator Murray
everyone agrees that Washington state
has been turning a deeper shade of blue
with each passing year
for example Joe Biden defeated Donald
Trump by a whopping 58 percent to 39
percent margin in the 2020 presidential
election and Murray prevailed in her
last re-election with a very comfortable
59 percent of the vote in 2016.
so Murray's alarming slide in the polls
could mean that Washington voters are
finally poised to vote for a change in
Direction
and do so at the senior senator's
expense
let's face it there's lots of reasons
for washingtonians to be sick and tired
of what's been happening right before
their eyes over the past two years
America has watched in disbelief as the
beautiful city of Seattle was overrun by
a rioting violent crime the defund the
police movement and the so-called chop
zones all the while entrenched out of
touch Democrats like Patty Murray have
joyfully plowed ahead with their failed
socialist agenda in Washington D.C due
to the Biden Murray policies
skyrocketing inflation in The Evergreen
State is making life exponentially more
difficult for hard-working families all
of Biden's irresponsible trillion dollar
spending bills could have been stopped
by Senator Murray if she had done the
right thing by voting no Republican
Challenger Tiffany Smiley's life story
represents precisely the kind of
political Outsider Washington State
needs in the United States Senate
she's a mother and a nurse who became a
strong advocate for our heroic veterans
after her husband Scott lost his
eyesight in a roadside bomb explosion
while serving in Iraq in 2005 with less
than five weeks to go until the midterm
elections control of the United States
Senate is up for grabs
in Tiffany Smiley voters in Washington
state have a candidate who will bring
common sense and a breath of fresh air
to Congress career politicians like
Patty Murray have put America in a deep
hole and it will take outsiders with
innovative ideas like Tiffany Smiley to
get us back on the right track this is
David bossi president of citizens united
listening to the Fox News rundown run
down stay up to date by subscribing to
this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
put the power of over 100 meteorologists
and the worldwide resources of fox in
your hands with the fox weather podcast
precise personal powerful subscribe and
listen now at foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes